I have one last two - I was going to say
trick property you know I want us
logarithm property to show you
so let me pick a suitably festive color
for this last property so let's say that
just you know I don't know X to the N is
equal to a alright nothing fancy there
well that's just a wave that's another
way of saying that log base X of a is
equal to n right
that's the exact same this is just an
exact same way of writing the exact same
thing just but you know once it's the
logarithm once an exponent right these
imply the same thing what we could do is
if the if n is actually equal to this
expression we can like I did a couple of
videos ago you can just substitute this
for n so we could write X to this thing
log base X a and we could set that is
equal to what a fascinating so now what
I'm going to do and actually this is
going to get pretty messy is I'm going
to raise actually let me let me let me
write this a little more space undo do
undo undo oh I can't keep on doing
anyway
so let me let me write it down here with
more space so I'm going to do something
fancy so ignore this so if I said X X to
the log base X of a that equals and
you'll see why I'm giving you some what
space right now equals a now what I want
to do is I want to raise both sides of
this equation to one over this exponent
right so I'm going to raise that to one
over log base X of a if I do something
to one side of the equation I have to do
it to the other so that's also that's
equal to a to 1 over log
base X of a I know this is quite a quite
daunting already but you'll see where
I'm going and hopefully not nothing I've
done is is completely non-intuitive
right I just you know this this
expression is just another way of
writing this expression and I
substituted for n and now I'm raising
both to this exponent and you'll see why
I'm doing that well if you're raising
something exponent and then you're
raising that to an exponent you just
multiply the two right so they cancel
out because this will be in the
numerator and this will be the
denominator so that gets us to let me
that gets us to this X to the 1 power
right because log base X of a over log
base X of a is equal to 1 so that's the
same thing as X is equal to a to the 1
over log base X of a you're probably
saying Sal where are you going with this
and I will short show you shortly
so we could also we could just replace a
with another variable right I could also
write X is also equal to B to the 1 over
log base X of B right nothing strange
there I just you know the same exact
thing I did today I could do with a with
the same thing I did with a I could be
with B so well I've written these two
expressions let me equal I mean I said X
is equal to both of these things so
let's let's set them equal to each other
so we know that a to 1 over log base X
of a is equal to B to the 1 over log
base X of B so what can we do now well
let's raise both of these actually I'm
running out of so much space let me
clear this and go to the next page or go
to another page whoops clear image
invert so what did I just write I said
that cuz I need a lot of space for what
I'm what I plan to do so I said a
to the one over log base X of a well
that equals B to the one over log base X
of B and hopefully you're satisfied with
that now let's raise both of these sides
to the log base X of B power so I'm
gonna read this log base X of B power
and guys hopefully you'll see why I'm
doing this well on this side they'll
cancel out right because this becomes a
numerator that's the denominator and on
this side you get a to the this becomes
the numerator right because we just
multiply the exponents log base X a
little dot is an X of B over log base X
of a and what is that equal well that
equals just B right because this over
this is one this B to the one that
equals B now let's write this entire
thing as a logarithm a to this thing is
equal to B that's the exact same thing
as saying that the logarithm base a of B
is equal to this thing is equal to the
log base X of B divided by the log base
X of a this might seem confusing and
might seem daunting but we're actually
going to a lot of examples of this and
this is probably the single most useful
identity I guess we could call it if
you're using a calculator why because
your calculator only has two bases and
either has log base you know base 10 or
base e right so if and and most of them
you know when you press the log button
on your calculator that it assumes log
base 10 so if I gave you a problem where
I wanted to know you know what is what
is let me switch colors because the
is my example color if I if I want to
say what is the log base 7 of 3 right
who know 7 to what power is 3 and
there's no easy way on most calculators
to do this well you can use this
identity that this is the same thing as
the log base 10 of 3 divided by the log
base 10 of 7 and these are very easy to
calculate on your calculator you just
type 3 and press log and it'll give you
this number and you press 7 and click on
log and I'll give you this number and
then you're done so hopefully you're
satisfied that this is true and you have
a little bit of an intuition of how to
use it and I'll make a bunch of videos
now on on actually how you can use these
longer than properties I just wanted to
get it out of the way so that you're
satisfied with it that they that they
are true I'll see you soon